it's important to emphasize that there's
still a lot of information in this case
that's yet to be disclosed and I think
the operative question is what the
actual charge will be if Donald Trump's
Intel is correct because that will
dictate to a large extent how serious of
a disturbance this is to Trump and what
we're in for for these next several
weeks and next several months and those
possibilities really could run the
Spectrum from something like a
relatively minor misdemeanor involving
misrepresenting business records to
something much more serious like a major
contravention of campaign Finance laws
that would be prosecuted as a felony and
technically could carry the possibility
of prison time but either way if Trump
is arrested and uh what he's saying is
correct then this does spell trouble for
him legally there's a saying that you
can indict a ham sandwich in New York so
this case is unlikely to lose Steam on
its own yeah he's going to continue on
I've never heard that saying about the
ham sandwich let's just go through the
sort of the gamut of the the legal
challenges that you could be facing you
say that the indictment could run from
the sort of misdemeanor to far more
serious and it's all based around this
payment for hush Money Paid that Michael
Cohen said a transform advisor and fixer
page two Stormy Daniels over that
alleged Affair and where that money came
from because Trump eventually reimbursed
Michael comb for it exactly I mean this
is a case that's important to emphasize
that's been going on for quite some time
several years there's a lot of players
involved a lot of accusations that have
been made and it's just really important
I think to emphasize that we don't know
what those charges will be um because it
could as I said before just involve
something relatively minor like
misrepresenting business documents but
if it actually was made in furtherance
of a larger crime dealing with the
campaign that's where the severity uh
becomes much more uh amped up and that's
where things like prison time start to
get uh talked about so it's just really
unclear at the moment would you still be
arrested for the misrepresentation of
documents would it still sort of involve
you know there's been talk of him being
put in handcuffs being fingerprinted
having a mug shot taken but that's what
happened if it was the lower end
well I I think that the charge for
Republicans is that it would if this is
a political Vendetta and selective
prosecution uh and so a lot of this
debate I think really does surround what
the charge is going to be because what
we hear from Defenders of Donald Trump
is yes this is something relatively uh
minor maybe it would be charged as a
misdemeanor but if it were anyone else
besides Donald Trump it would probably
be treated in a way that is much more uh
quiet but because it's Trump because
he's so high profile because there's an
accusation that this district attorney
uh is liberal and maybe pursuing some
type of political Vendetta they're just
trying to make a show about it that we
just don't know
um and so we'll see how that shakes out
and of course we saw the the message
that you posted on Truth socially talks
about fighting and taking back our
country or words to that effect I mean
what impact do you think that will have
because it's very similar language that
was used before the Insurrection on
Capitol Hill back in January the 6th
you're absolutely right Kamali this
could definitely play I think into
Trump's hands politically and Trump
already is using this case to rev up the
base and his comments on true social
calling for protest and to take the
country back but really just a harbinger
of more to come it's all part of Trump's
repertoire that this is a Witch Hunt
it's a political Vendetta it's
overzealous prosecution by radical
district attorney to it's a George Soros
funded hijab this is the kind of
language that we're in for and that
we're already hearing it's very similar
as you suggested uh to what we heard in
the lead up to January 6th it's also
kind of reminiscent of impeachment 1.0
impeachment 2.0 the search of Mar-A-Lago
and of course we know that when it comes
to Trump's most committed base it
doesn't take much to get them to go on
to the offensive so he's going to sort
of use this for all that it's worth
thank you very much for being with us
thank you